[Music]
I'm Connor I work at a company called
Fishtown analytics as pizza were based
in Philadelphia in the United States so
we sort of do two things
we're in analytics consultancy and we
work with a lot of awesome companies
around the world helping them build out
their analytics discipline in addition
to that and in service of that we build
a handful of open-source tools most
notably DBT which I'm here to talk about
today so I just want to say that like we
are practitioners first and foremost we
do work that spans the entire data stack
with our clients and from analytics to
data science to data engineering we work
with companies of a lot of different
sizes and so we come to this talk and
come to DBT from a very practical
standpoint this is a tool that like we
actively use a lot of people actively
use it and that's sort of how it's
informed rather than yeah the arete
achill or more academic approach so I
want to start by asking a loaded
question maybe which is what do data
engineers do I think if we like all went
around the room and came up with our own
personal answer to this we'd come up
with a lot of different answers and I
like to look at this from an
organization standpoint from a rural
standpoint so organizationally I think
data engineers do two things they fill
two roles the first is that we are
shepherds so we Shepherd data from point
A to point B through a series of
pipelines we make sure that the data
actually ends up where it needs to be
second were librarians so because we
like write all the low-level code that
moves data around usually we are a
really good reference for
helping someone at our organization
understand where a piece of data comes
from or how an aggregation is computed
or how a specific metric is computed so
often we're sort of the last line of
defense against you no questions
interrogating the data for what's there
and like we're engineers we automate
these things we aren't like taking
stacks of spreadsheets and manually
copying data data over and passing that
on the point is to automate as much of
this as we can but I would argue that we
often don't do enough in the context of
this stack so just to illustrate that
and I have a quick case study here this
is from a company that I worked with in
2017 for about six months they're a
medium-sized hardware and software
hybrid tech company so they have a lot
of physical presences in major cities
and they also have a major software
stack the data team at that time
consisted of one data engineer and one
analyst and their manager so this is a
very small team and probably a little
bit different than then you know some
more of a start-up environment but I
think it's a representative sample
because this is sort of the structure of
the teams that we generally look at and
this is what their stack looked like so
like I said they had physical presences
in a number of major cities they had
data pipelines that would take those
systems they would take the application
databases and the API endpoints that
those systems presented they would
replicate all the data out they'd do
some simple transformations to get all
of the data into a consistent schema
across the different cities then they
would warehouse it into a very large
redshift cluster then they had some
other processes that worked off of that
sort of like main pipe so they read data
out of the redshift cluster transform it
write it back in
they build views do these sorts of
things on redshift and then finally they
use looker as their BI tools so their
analysts ultimately just ran queries and
looker to understand what was happening
with this data now there is a pretty big
problem with this in their use case
which is their data engineer was
responsible for this entire thing so
like every line of code that was written
related to transforming data in their
stack or to managing any of the data in
their stack was handled by their data
engineer and their analyst who used
looker and understood the data really
well but really their role in
contributing to the stack was limited to
ideas so they thought of a new type of
analysis that they wanted to do for
example one of the things that they had
a hard time doing at the time that we
started working with them was getting
sort of advanced retention analytics on
their global data set so they really had
a hard time looking at retention across
all of these cities they could do it
really well on an individual City but it
was hard to do it across all the cities
so ultimately it was just a resource
problem right they had one data engineer
whose job it was to do all of this stuff
and ultimately I think what they wanted
was part to help us optimize the stack
but also to sort of free up their data
engineer from managing all the you know
nuances of their transformations from
keeping the red shift cluster running
and in good health all these things to
doing more like data engineering work so
I think that Jeff Magnuson sort of very
concisely stated the problem here in a
way that I really like by saying
engineers must deploy platforms services
abstractions and frameworks that allow
data scientists or in our case study
data analysts to conceive of deploy
develop and deploy their ideas with
autonomy so in our case study the data
scientist could conceive of the ideas
but there really wasn't any mechanism
for them to develop these ideas or
actually deploy them into their data
stack
so this is sort of the big idea in
Fishtown analytics in behind DBT it's
what if we gave our analysts first sort
of their own transformation space so
they already live in the warehouse they
know how to use the warehouse and we can
sort of give them their own space to in
which to work to accomplish some of
their own goals without needing to rely
on the data engineers to accomplish
those goals
second we could give them a data
catalogue so instead of directly
answering questions we can provide a
catalogue of all the data that's in the
warehouse and they can answer those
questions for themselves so it's really
making them a lot more autonomous saving
our engineers a lot of time and letting
the data engineers focus on the stuff
that really they can only do which is
you know all the hard technical stuff
and you know making these stacks run
really smoothly and so on so this is
sort of our reimagined vision of how
this world looks so there's still this
part that the data engineer owns where
the data gets read out of the source
systems it's passed through pipelines
it's written into the raw data schemas
in the warehouse but then there's some
other thing that the analysts own that
the draw data passes through to put out
transform data all inside the context of
the warehouse right because that's where
they're very comfortable
and finally that transform data can feed
into looker and all these other
processes that that we want to run so in
this scenario the data engineers are
collaborating on this sort of purple
area by providing the platform for these
things to run on but the analysts are
actually the ones doing most of the
implementation of sequel code so this is
the idea behind DBT DBT is an open
source command line based transformation
tool it's designed for all of the sequel
authors at your organization so often at
very small organizations it's used by
like the CEO or somebody who understands
sequel and really wants answers to these
questions and as the organization grows
that can become
a whole bunch of different people who
might understand sequel it's about two
years old we have a little over 250
weekly active projects so it's still
pretty young and not that widely used
but importantly it's a hundred percent
free and open source so from here I'm
gonna kind of give you a whirlwind tour
of all the functionality included in DBT
you can get all of this today by just
running pip install DBT or you can visit
the website and learn a little bit more
so DBT is a developer tool or at least
it acts like one so I think a good
comparison might be something like
terraform there's a command-line
interface that we use in a development
workflow to deploy data models to the
warehouse and this means that your team
members including your analysts end up
working in the terminal and in a text
editor this is a little bit strange for
a lot of analysts at first it's a new
set of tools but we've had a like
amazing success training analysts on how
to use this stack and we found that
they're really eager to get involved
with managing the transformations
they've write sequel transformations
then they execute them using DBT then
they automated test them which we'll
talk about that DBT has some automated
testing functionality built into it and
finally they go through you know QA a
validation deployment to production so
in short when using DBT your analysts
behave like software developers they go
through the same process that software
developers go through just a quick note
on sequel DBT only supports sequel it
doesn't support Python it doesn't
support our it doesn't support Scala or
anything like that and this in a lot of
ways is a limitation of DBT but it turns
out that modern data warehouses can
actually handle a lot so right now it
works with Postgres with redshift and
with snowflake and Google bigquery we
sort of are ready to accept more plugins
to connect to more data bases and really
what we're lacking there is domain
expertise in these specific databases
so for example we would love to be
compatible with link but we just don't
have the local domain expertise to build
that thing out and do it right so if
you're interested in using this and you
don't see your warehouse on this list
come talk to me after it we'd be happy
to hear more about sort of how you can
help us add that to DBT okay so this is
the development workflow that I
described for DBT and we're just going
to walk through these steps really
quickly so first your analysts rights
equal in their text editor and the
atomic unit of transformation in DBT is
called a model so the code that they're
actually writing is represented in
sequel scripts that they put into a git
repository and when DBT executes this
model each model corresponds to one
object in the warehouse so we're either
building a view or a table or something
else but each model always has one
output in the warehouse so we kind of
understand from a DBT project what the
outputs are and you can see here an
example invocation so on the command
line we can type DBT run - model
accounts and that will run just the
accounts model that we have defined on
the right here so I mentioned that DBT
models are mapped to one output
DBT models also define their inputs
through a the use of a special ginger
function called ref so in a DBT model
you use this thing called ref you ref at
able and what that does is it builds an
edge in a dag so DBT can represent the
dag of your entire project and it also
replaces that ref call with the local
version of your table that sounds a
little confusing but we'll sort of dive
into an example of that later on but so
what's DBT has that dag it can really
traverse any part of your graph in any
order that you're interested in having
to do so so this is really great for
development when you're just tweaking
one transformation and you want to build
just that transformation and all the
downstream ones so this is an example of
how we would run the identity model and
all of its children and all of it
parents and I have some more examples
that we'll get into later but this is a
this is a screenshot of our DBT
documentation tool of a dag that we
built specifically for this talk and
this is supposed to model typical like
web event data so in DBT in your raw
data schema in your warehouse you might
have a web events table and like
something around page view timing
how do those events map to actual
pageviews and from there we can start to
build up all the constructs that your
analysts actually want to analyze in the
warehouse so we can build page views and
then from there we can session eyes
those page views and then we can map the
identities in those sessions from the
rest of the warehouse into this local
web event data and then finally we can
combine that into the like
be-all-end-all user's model that unites
all these these data sources into one
model this is a more realistic dag this
is actually from our own internal
project it's very common for these
projects to grow to like hundreds and
hundreds of models with complex tags I
think that this is interesting for a
couple reasons first because it really
shows you that like there's a lot of
logic that people want to express here
this isn't something that ends up having
you know 10 or 15 models once analysts
get their hands on this there's a lot
that they want to do there's a lot of
abstractions that they want to build and
there's a lot of different ways that
they want to connect data together
second you know to the sequel warehouses
point warehouses handle this kind of DAG
building really well so it turns out
that you can build hundreds of tables
pretty effectively in some of these
warehouses and many hundreds is about as
far as we've gotten we haven't gotten to
the thousands yet but so far so good
so we talked about writing sequel we
talked about Dex now let's talk about
how we actually use DBT to build out
these tags in the warehouse so I
mentioned that DBT can select different
parts of the dag to execute and here we
just have a few quick examples of how
you might do this how you might actually
invoke DBT to make these things happen
so the first one if we just call DBT run
from any environment it's gonna build
all of the models in the entire project
and if we provide a specific what we
call a model selection syntax we can
tell it which specific models in the
project to build so we can either run
one specific model we can run a model
and all of the downstream models we can
run a model in all of its inputs and so
on and importantly this works the same
way everywhere so when you run DBT and
development with your project code there
it's gonna work exactly the same way as
when you deploy this thing to production
and run that code there there's no sort
of like special framework that you need
to run these things in production all
you do in production is the same thing
you did locally dip install DBT move the
code over there run DBT from production
and everything will just work so
materializations are a concept built
into DBT that defined how to actually
turn one of these sequel statements into
a warehouse object and DBT has a few
built-in it has the basic view and table
build so we can take a select statement
and then go from the Select statement to
like a create table as query where we
just copy all of the contents of that
select statement into a brand new table
similar with views we can run create
view as and generate a view that can be
reused maybe more interestingly is
something called an incremental model so
the idea of an incremental model is
given an input table that has a primary
key and a destination table that we
previously generated with the same
primary key we can look at an updated
add field on the source table and find
all the updates that need to be passed
on to the destination table and actually
go through do the updates do the deletes
and the destination table where
necessary and then append all the new
records to the destination table so for
like very
and only data sets like event streams
this ends up being a very efficient way
to sort of pull event salam in your
warehouse into your final model without
needing to like copy extra data over as
you go okay so now that we've written
some sequel we've actually built some
models in the warehouse we have the
ability to run automated tests on them
so this is just like a good practice in
software development right we always
want to automate a test to prevent bugs
from hitting production it's a little
weird to think about this in a data
context as I'm sure a lot of you know in
a warehouse context automated tests can
usually catch things like bad
calculations they're really good at
catching bad joins or fanouts they're
really good at detecting schema
mismatches and DBT provides this sort of
functionality via tests of two different
kinds so the first one and the more
basic one is sequel tests so a test in
DBT is a select statement that retrieves
failing records from the warehouse so
any query that you can write that
retrieves a list of failing records from
your warehouse can be used in DBT as a
test in this example we're running this
query select star from accounts where ID
is not null so if there are any records
where ID is null will get a list of
those back we'll pass those on to the
test
db2 we'll mark that test has failed and
then our test run will fail so from
there there's a more sort of structured
way that we can specify these tests
called schema tests and these map pretty
closely to like constraints in a
traditional relational database system a
lot of these warehouses don't come with
that out of the box for a lot of really
good reasons but often you want to like
go back and retroactively lis test
whether those constraints are in place
without necessarily like preventing raw
data from making it into the warehouse
so out-of-the-box DBT supports
uniqueness not null and foreign key
constraints and in this schema demo file
here on the right if you look at this
not in all tests here that's exactly the
same test that we were just looking at
so we're asserting that the ID field on
the accounts too
is not null you can also define your own
custom schema tests I won't get into
that but it's something that you can do
so here's an example of how you would
invoke that test right so we can run
DBT test with the same exact model
selection syntax that we used for models
and it will select all the tests for
those models execute them and hopefully
they'll pass okay so finally we have
written sequel we've run it we run tests
everything looks good now we can move on
to sort of validation and deployment so
the first like really important
validation and deployment thing that DBT
ships with is a documentation generator
so this does a few things it looks at
all the models in your project it looks
at all the metadata provided in the
schema diamo files finally it actually
builds a catalog of your warehouse and
it uses all of this information to build
a like fully materialized catalog for
your warehouse that we can then use to
generate a documentation website so this
is a screenshot of what the DBT
documentation website looks like this is
for this test project that I was just
showing you so there's a couple things
that I want to point out here first if
you look on the left here you can see
that we can navigate this site either
via the structure in the database so
like all the schemas that are in the
database that we care about or by the
actual like structure of our DBT project
contained in this documentation we're
currently looking at the documentation
for the sessions table and we can do
things like write a description for the
sessions table specify who the person is
that someone should talk to if it's
unclear what data is in there or if they
think they found a bug in that table as
well as just providing like general
documentation of what this thing is and
what it does you could see at the bottom
here - I don't have a screenshot of this
but we have a listing of all of the
columns there data types as well as all
of the test constraints that we've
applied to those columns so when we get
to the demo I'll show you a little bit
more
that next we have a view into the source
and compiled sequel for the model
so in this sessions file this is the
actual raw sequel that lives there and
you can see that there's unrendered
Jinja inside this sequel when we go to
actually compile this thing you can see
that it has replaced that config block
with just nothing it's just rendered it
out and the DB GC excuse me the ref two
pageviews it's replaced with a call to
the DB TC MacArthur schema the pageviews
table so what's interesting about this
is I'm running this in a development
context right now in a brand new schema
called DB TC McArthur and everything the
DB T builds and interacts with in that
context is going to be isolated to that
schema so it's totally isolated from the
production transformation build that we
could execute that would live in a
separate ski moon would be totally
totally isolated from this so next if we
click this little pop-out thing on the
bottom right we can get just like a
quick view of the dag for this specific
model so here this is just the direct
parents and children so you can see that
this depends on pageviews and as we saw
before sessions is used to build
identity and then users later on and if
we go like full screen with this we can
get like the full dag of all of the
sequel transformations in this project
so this the screenshot that I showed you
before is just this this is a fully
interactive graph that you can use to
interact with all the models that live
in in your project so I want to touch
just a little bit on deployment of these
things to production and then I have a
quick demo for you guys so repeatability
is a really key feature of DBT meaning
that running DBT twice on the same set
of inputs should always yield the same
output so that means that each user can
build their own feature branches in
development they can run those things
against the warehouse build out other
models then they can run a continuous
integration process on these do the
automated tests on them build out the
development or the staging schema then
deploy to production
having all of the you know checks that
you would normally have in a continuous
integration process in place so this
looks just like any other software
project that you would work on our users
have deployed DBT with a bunch of tools
we have a SAS back-end that we've
developed called Center there's a bunch
of cron like schedulers that people have
used so like air flow kubernetes cron a
lot of people deploy with kubernetes
scheduled jobs so they'll pack this up
into a docker container ship it to their
kubernetes cluster and then trigger that
thing to run every hour or whenever a
data load completes her you know however
they see fit to do that there's also
this class of CI tools so get lab CI
circle CI Travis CI where a push to
master triggers a deployment of the
production models but they can also
build on pull requests and do all these
other things that don't want to do okay
so I have a quick demo of everything to
show you let's do this
that's somewhat legible so the first
thing that we're gonna do here is run
basically we're gonna seed my test
database with test data set so we can do
that by running this command called DBT
seed and I think I need to start docker
yeah so DBT seed is a thing that we
really didn't touch on at all this is
sort of a useful feature for testing and
that sort of thing that's built into DBT
but basically the ideas it can take a
set of CSV files that you provide and
build those CSV files out into actual
tables in your warehouse so like in this
demo project where we really just want
some dummy data that we can test on we
have the ability to just take this like
realistic-looking csv file
dump it into the warehouse and build off
of that
this is often also useful for like very
small test environments so if you want a
subset of your data to like you want to
grab 10,000 records that you then want
to test in your local environment as
you're developing you can often do it
using this and basically create like
fixtures for your project
come on docker
all right
how about that all right that looks
better
there we go okay so you can see we took
those two CSV files we inserted the
records into these tables that's pretty
straightforward so next we can actually
run the dag that we just showed so I'm
just gonna do TBT run and you're gonna
see it's gonna go through and create a
handful of views and then a handful of
tables notably we're only running this
thing with one thread so DBT is just
gonna run everything in serial order
but DBT has the ability to run this with
multiple threads really the constraint
here is how much your warehouse can
handle not how much DBT can handle so if
you want to run this with 30 threads and
your house can handle that
more power to you but you still have to
DBT will still sort of resolve the
critical path here though and always
follow the dag order when it's building
these things okay so we built these six
models that looked pretty
straightforward now let's build our
let's run our tests so we have some
tests to find for this dummy project
that we're gonna run and you can see so
we grant 14 tests and these tests are
mostly of the variety that we looked at
in the schema demo file so they're all
like testing uniqueness on this session
ID field of the sessions table or a
testing we can do foreign key
relationships right so the session ID
field of the pageviews table Maps
one-to-one with the session ID field of
the session stable now one of these
tests failed here right so we could see
at the end that DBT exited with code 1
which is great like we wanted to exit
with that status when it fails and it
told us a little bit about which tests
failed and also notably here it gives us
the path that it wrote the compiled
sequel out to so if we just cat this
file we can see here the actual query
the DBT ran to run this test and you
know copy this thing out and run it
ourselves so finally we can run a
command called DBT Doc's generate and
this is the thing that's actually going
to inspect our warehouse and build up a
catalog of everything that's there
now we can actually so you can see here
it says it wrote the catalogue to Target
catalog now JSON so if we look at this
file you're actually see that DBT just
writes out a file that has all of this
information in it and a structured
format in JSON so this is really like
the output of DBT DBT Doc's just
consumes this up and gives you a website
but if you did want to wire this up more
programmatically with the rest of your
stack you could consume these JSON files
that DBT spits out and just sort of like
wire it fields up that way
okay so we've generated the docs we have
this catalog file in place finally we
can run DBT Doc's serve and that's just
going to run a local web server that
actually serves up this interactive
documentation site so now you know we
can go through and take a look at
exactly what we were just looking at
before you could see we have sessions
table we have a description we have a
list of columns with the constraints
specified right here and column level
descriptions that we can sort of
customize in the context of this project
everything is built into a schema called
DBT see McArthur which is what I
specified for this local development run
and finally we can sort of pull out the
dag and interact with that dynamically
as we sort of use this site
okay
that's it thank you for listening
actually leave this up here so you guys
can take a look at it thanks everyone
for listening hi great presentation and
it's great too you mentioned a beginning
that you support limited number of SQL
service
I haven't spine found the Microsoft SQL
Server that we use in our company all
the time okay so how difficult it would
be to support it for a sequel server
specifically yes yes so we have actually
implemented two other we call them
adapters database adapters then other
than the ones that I showed you one of
them was sequel server we built a sequel
server and Azure data warehouse support
for this and the problem that we ran
into was like I said when we started to
use it with a client we hit a point
where we basically said like hey this
isn't working you should not use sequel
server like we should move you to
something else and so we it was more a
lack of our ability to like fully
optimize that setup than it was that
DBT could interact with that tool so
anyway we have the code ready I would
love to talk to you after and maybe have
you take a look at it and tell us maybe
what we were doing wrong but really the
the the meat of what needs to be done
here is implementing those
materializations that tell DBT how do
you go from a select statement into this
sort of item potent repeatably built
table and it
we found some areas where that was slow
or it didn't work exactly how we wanted
it to
you